We all know we're tracked
everywhere we go.
But as a lawyer, a technologist
and anti-surveillance activist,
I'm here to tell you two things:
the threat is way worse than you realize
and the solutions simpler than you think.
And no, it's not wearing a tinfoil hat.
(Laughter)
You may know that advertisers
can record every link you click
and every place you've been,
but you may not realize
the government can buy that data, too.
If the NYPD wants to track a BLM protest,
they can buy the data.
If Texas wants to watch
an abortion clinic,
they can buy the data.
And when the IRS wants to know
if your Florida company
is really doing work in California,
they don't need to buy the data.
They already did.
Millions of our location records.
And what the government can't buy,
it can take by force,
crudely wielding
our 18th century constitution
against 21st century technology.
With a geofence warrant,
companies are forced to hand over
our location data -- not for one person,
but everyone, every single user
in a geographic area,
whether a single room or an entire city.
In one Virginia case,
police cast a digital dragnet
far beyond the crime scene,
forcing Google
to identify everyone nearby,
even those at a church,
even though they weren't even suspects.
It's not only Orwellian,
it's bad policing.
Search widely enough
and someone's movements
will always look suspicious.
Like an Arizona man wrongly arrested
for murder miles away
simply because someone was logged
into his Google account.
Or a Florida man
connected to a crime scene
for biking around the neighborhood.
Look, I don't know about you,
but I find it hard enough
to work up the energy to work out
without worrying that my Fitbit
is going to land me in jail.
(Laughter)
Technology makes tracking possible,
but it's our laws that give it force,
posing a deeply discriminatory danger
to BIPOC communities,
LGBTQ individuals
and undocumented families.
We can't continue to watch officers
shred the Fourth Amendment safeguards
against search and seizure.
We can't wait for
the Supreme Court to act.
We must ban geofence warrants
and other surveillance abuses today.
(Applause)
For years, privacy advocates have fought
how companies collect our data.
And we failed.
Maybe we should have tried
the tinfoil hats after all.
But we can stop mass surveillance
if we change the problem
we're trying to fix.
Shifting our focus
from how companies collect our data
to how governments abuse it.
In America, our default rule is
that every smartphone, computer
and Internet-enabled toaster oven
is a police tool in the making.
Officers can seize our devices
and wiretap Alexa,
but they don't control
the contours of our Constitution.
It's our decision,
our democratic decision,
whether our data can be used
for undemocratic ends.
We can create new firewalls
to protect our information --
not computer code, but legal codes
that shield us from having our data
used against us in a court of law.
Legal firewalls are already becoming
a reality in New York.
At the pandemic's height,
we feared how police and ICE
might misuse data
from new contact tracing apps
that monitor everyone nearby.
So we worked with the New York
Civil Liberties Union,
doctors, grassroots organizers
to create the first ban on police access
to contact tracing data in the country.
No one should fear
that they'll be arrested
because of public health data,
but that remains a risk in 49 states.
Legal firewalls let us have our technology
and our Constitution too,
enabling innovation
by outlawing oppression.
We see glimmers of Beltway bipartisanship,
but state and local governments
are our brightest hope.
That's because it can take
millions of people
to enact a national statute,
but just a handful of committed activists
can make changes in their community.
And we already see a deluge
of state and local protections,
including a bill I helped write,
New York's first in the nation ban
on geofence warrants.
(Applause)
Thank you.
And even some courts agree.
Just last month,
a federal judge struck down
that sprawling Virginia geofence,
calling on state lawmakers
to enact bills like my own.
As a teenage protester,
NYPD camcorders shoved in my face,
I saw surveillance as a threat,
and people thought my fears
were something out of science fiction.
Today, they increasingly think
that surveillance is inevitable
and that privacy is the fantasy.
But I'm actually
more optimistic than ever.
It had to get this bad
for the denial to break
and for the public to act.
I know we can push back
that looming dystopia.
I know we can protect everything
that technology
might make possible tomorrow,
but only if we ban
surveillance abuses today.
Thank you.
(Applause)